In order to understand how procedures are
implemented on the beta, we will take a look
at a mystery function and its translation
into beta assembly code.
The mystery function is shown here:
The function f takes an argument x as an input.
It then performs a logical AND operation on
the input x and the constant 5 to produce
the variable a.
After that, it checks if the input x is equal
to 0, and if so returns the value 0, otherwise
it returns an unknown value which we need
to determine.
We are provided with the translation of this
C code into beta assembly as shown here.
We take a closer look at the various parts
of this code to understand how this function
as well as procedures in general work on the
beta.
The code that calls the procedure is responsible
for pushing any arguments onto the stack.
This is shown in pink in the code and on the
stack.
If there are multiple arguments then they
are pushed in reverse order so that the first
argument is always in the same location relative
to the BP, or base pointer, register which
we will see in a moment.
The BR instruction branches to label f after
storing the return address, which is b, into
the LP, or linkage pointer, register.
In yellow, we see the entry sequence for the
procedure.
The structure of this entry sequence is identical
for all procedures.
The first thing it does is PUSH(LP) which
pushes the LP register onto the stack immediately
after the arguments that were pushed onto
the stack by the caller.
Next it pushes the BP onto the stack in order
to save the most recent value of the BP register
before updating it.
Now, a MOVE(SP, BP) is performed.
SP is the stack pointer which always points
to the next empty location on the stack.
At the time that this MOVE operation is executed,
the SP, points to the location immediately
following the saved BP.
This move instruction makes the BP point to
the same location that the SP is currently
pointing to, which is the location that is
immediately following the saved BP.
Note, that once the BP register is set up,
one can always find the first argument at
location BP – 12 (or in other words, 3 words
before the current BP register).
If there was a second argument, it could be
found in location BP – 16, and so on.
Next, we allocate space on the stack for any
local variables.
This procedure allocates space for one local
variable.
Finally, we push all registers that are going
to be modified by our procedure onto the stack.
Doing this makes it possible to recover the
registers' original values once the procedure
completes execution.
In this example, register R1 is saved onto
the stack.
Once the entry sequence is complete, the BP
register still points to the location immediately
following the saved BP.
The SP, however, now points to the location
immediately following the saved R1 register.
So for this procedure, after executing the
entry sequence, the stack has been modified
as shown here.
The procedure return, or exit, sequence for
all beta procedures follows the same structure.
It is assumed that the return value for the
procedure has already been placed into register
R0.
Next, all registers that were used in the
procedure body, are restored to their original
values.
This is followed by deallocating all of the
local variables from the stack.
We then restore the BP, followed by the LP
register.
Finally, we jump to LP which contains the
return address of our procedure.
In this case, LP contains the address b which
is the address of the next instruction that
should be executed following the execution
of the f procedure.
Taking a closer look at the details for our
example, we see that we begin our exit sequence
with POP(R1) in order to restore the original
value of register R1.
Note that this also frees up the location
on the stack that was used to store the value
of R1.
Next, we get rid of the local variables we
stored on the stack.
This is achieved using the MOVE(BP, SP) instruction
which makes the SP point to the same location
as the BP thus specifying that all the locations
following the updated SP are now considered
unused.
Next, we restore the BP register.
Restoring the BP register is particularly
important for nested procedure calls.
If we did not restore the BP register, then
upon return to the calling procedure, the
calling procedure would no longer have a correct
BP, so it would not be able to rely on the
fact that it's first argument is located at
location BP-12, for example.
Finally, we restore the LP register and JMP
to the location of the restored LP register.
This is the return address, so by jumping
to LP, we return from our procedure call and
are now ready to execute the next instruction
at label b.
Now let's get back to our original procedure
and its translation to beta assembly.
We will now try to understand what this mystery
function is actually doing by examining the
remaining sections of our assembly code highlighted
here.
Let's zoom into the highlighted code.
The LD instruction loads the first argument
into register R0.
Recall that the first argument can always
be found at location BP – 12, or in other
words, 3 words before the current BP register.
This means that the value x is loaded into
R0.
Next we perform a binary AND operation between
R0 and the constant 5, and store the result
of that operation into register R1.
Note that its okay to overwrite R1 because
the entry sequence already saved a copy of
the original R1 onto the stack.
Also, note that overwriting R0 is considered
fine because we ultimately expect the result
to be returned in R0, so there is no expectation
of maintaining the original value of R0.
Looking back at the c code of our function,
we see that the bitwise AND of x and 5 is
stored into a local variable named a.
In our entry sequence, we allocated 1 word
on the stack for our local variables.
That is where we want to store this intermediate
result.
The address of this location is equal to the
contents of the BP register.
Since the destination of a store operation
is determined by adding the contents of the
last register in the instruction to the constant,
the destination of this store operation is
the value of BP + 0.
So as expected, variable a is stored at the
location pointed to by the BP register.
Now we check if x equals 0 and if so we want
to return the value 0.
This is achieved in beta assembly by checking
if R0 is equal to 0 since R0 was loaded with
the value of x by the LD operation.
The BEQ operation checks whether or not this
condition holds and if so, it branches to
label bye which is our exit sequence.
In that situation, we just saw that R0 = 0,
so R0 already contains the correct return
value and we are ready to execute our return
sequence.
If x is not equal to 0, then we perform the
instructions after label xx.
By figuring out what these instructions do,
we can identify the value of our mystery function
labeled ?????.
We begin by decrementing R0 by 1.
This means that R0 will be updated to hold
x-1.
We then push this value onto the stack and
make a recursive call to procedure f.
In other words, we call f again with a new
argument which is equal to x-1.
So far we know that our mystery function will
contain the term f(x-1).
We also see that LP gets updated with the
new return address which is yy + 4.
So just before our recursive call to f with
the new argument x-1, our stack looks like
this.
After the procedure entry sequence is executed
in the first recursive call, our stack looks
like this.
Note that this time the saved LP is yy + 4
because that is our return address for the
recursive procedure call.
The previous BP points to where the BP was
pointing to in the original call to f.
Another term for this group of stack elements
is the activation record.
In this example, each activation record consists
of 5 elements.
These are the argument to f, the saved LP,
the saved BP, the local variable, and the
saved R1.
Each time that f is called recursively another
activation record will be added to the stack.
When we finally return from all of these recursive
calls, we are back to a stack that looks like
this with a single activation record left
on the stack plus the first argument with
which the recursive call was made.
The DEALLOCATE(1) instruction then removes
this argument from the stack.
So the SP is now pointing to the location
where we previously pushed the argument x-1.
R0 holds the return value from the recursive
call to f which is the value of f(x-1).
Now, we execute a LD into register R1 of the
address that is the contents of register BP
+ 0.
This value is a.
We then ADD R1 to R0 to produce our final
result in R0.
R0 is now equal to a + f(x-1), so we have
discovered that our mystery function is a
+ f(x-1).
Before we continue with analyzing a stack
trace from this problem, let's answer a few
simpler questions.
The first question is whether or not variable
a, from the statement a = x & 5, is stored
on the stack and if so where is it stored
relative to the BP register.
Earlier we saw that our assembly program allocates
space for one local variable on the stack.
It then stores R1, which holds the result
of performing a binary ANDC between x and
the constant 5, into the location pointed
to by the BP register, as shown here.
Next, we want to translate the instruction
at label yy into its binary representation.
The instruction at label yy is BR(f, LP).
This instruction is actually a macro that
translates to a BEQ(R31, f, LP).
Note that because R31 always equals 0, this
branch is always taken.
The format of the binary representation for
this instruction is a 6-bit opcode, followed
by a 5 bit Rc identifier, followed by another
5 bits which specify Ra, and then followed
by a 16 bit literal.
The opcode for BEQ is 011100.
Rc = LP which is register R28.
The 5-bit encoding of 28 is 11100.
Ra is R31 whose encoding is 11111.
Now, we need to determine the value of the
literal in this instruction.
The literal in a branch instruction stores
the offset measured in words from the instruction
immediately following the branch, to the destination
address.
Looking at our assembly code for this function,
we see that we want to count the number of
words from the DEALLOCATE(1) instruction back
to label f.
Recall that the PUSH and POP macros are actually
each made of up two instructions so each of
those counts as 2 words.
Counting back, and accounting for the two
instructions per push and pop, we see that
we have to go back 16 instructions, so our
literal is -16 expressed as a 16 bit binary
number.
Positive 16 is 0000 0000 0001 0000, so -16
is 1111 1111 1111 0000.
Now, suppose that the function f is called
from an external main program, and the machine
is halted when a recursive call to f is about
to execute the BEQ instruction tagged xx.
The BP register of the halted machine contains
0x174, and the hex contents of a region of
memory are shown here.
The values on the left of the stack are the
addresses of each location on the stack.
We first want to determine the current value
of the SP, or stack pointer, register.
We were told that the machine is halted when
a recursive call to f is about to execute
the BEQ instruction tagged xx.
And that the BP register was 0x174 at that
point.
We see that after the BP was updated to be
equal to the SP in the MOVE operation, two
additional entries were made on the stack.
The first was an ALLOCATE instruction which
allocated space for one local variable, thus
making the SP point to location 0x178, and
then PUSH(R1), which saves a copy of R1 on
the stack, thus moving the SP register one
further location down to 0x17C.
We now want to answer some questions about
the stack trace itself to help us better understand
its structure.
We first want to determine the value of local
variable a in the current stack frame.
We know that a is stored at location BP +
0.
So a is the variable stored at address 0x174,
and that value is 5.
From here, we can label all the entries in
the stack trace as follows.
We saw earlier, that each activation record
consists of 5 words, the argument x followed
by the saved LP, the saved BP, the local variable,
and the saved register R1.
We can apply this structure to label our stack
trace.
Now that our stack trace is fully labeled
we can take a closer look at the details of
implementing procedures on the beta.
We begin by looking at the multiple LP values
that were stored on the stack.
Note that the first one at address 0x144 has
a value of 0x5C whereas the following two
have a value of 0xA4.
This occurs because the LP value stored at
address 0x144 is the return address from the
main procedure that originally called procedure
f, whereas the following two LP values are
the return addresses from recursive calls
to f made from within the f function itself.
Using this information you can now answer
the question: What is the address of the BR
instruction that made the original call to
f from the external main program?
Recall that the value stored in the LP register
is actually the return address which is the
address of the instruction immediately following
the branch instruction.
So if the original LP value was 0x5C, that
means that the address of the branch instruction
was 0x58.
We can also answer the question, what is the
value of the PC when the program is halted.
We know that the program was halted just before
executing the instruction at label xx.
We also know, that the instruction at label
yy makes a recursive call to f.
We know that the LP value from the recursive
calls is 0xA4.
This means that the address of the DEALLOCATE(1)
instruction is 0xA4.
Counting backwards by 4 bytes, and accounting
for the fact that a PUSH operation consists
of two instructions, we see that label xx
= 0x90 and that is the value of the PC when
the program is halted.
As our last question, we want to consider
the following: Suppose that you are told that
you could delete 4 instructions from your
program without affecting the behavior of
the program.
The 4 instructions to be removed are a LD,
a ST, an ALLOCATE, and a MOVE instruction.
Removing these instructions would make our
program shorter and faster.
So, our goal is to determine whether or not
this is possible without affecting the behavior
of the program.
Let's first consider removing the ALLOCATE
instruction.
If this instruction is removed, that means
that we will not be saving space on the stack
for local variable a.
However, if we take a closer look at the 3
lines of code highlighted in yellow, we see
that the actual value of a is first computed
in R1 before storing it in local variable
a.
Since R1 is going to be saved on the stack
during each recursive call, we could get away
without saving a on the stack because we can
find its value in the stored R1 of the next
activation record as shown in the highlighted
pairs of a and R1 on the stack.
This means that we could safely remove the
ALLOCATE instruction.
As a result, this also means that we don't
need the ST operation that stores a on the
stack or the LD operation that reloads a into
register R1.
Finally, because there are no longer any local
variables stored on the stack, then the instruction
MOVE(BP,SP) which is normally used to deallocate
all local variables, can be skipped because
after popping R1, the BP and SP registers
will already point to the same location.
So, in conclusion the 4 operations can be
removed from the program without changing
the behavior of the code.